jayakumar Christine with gold rush in
India this is my first opportunity here
at the in the economic summit it's been
a great experience being great
opportunity for a non-profit just right
probably private partnership with the
corporate India and the government it
has also been an opportunity for to
contribute to the thought leadership of
the country especially in their ship
from shareholder to stakeholder to be
sure that the 836 million Indians who
are below two dollars a day are included
in their definition of stakeholders and
to be able to really bring the for the
needs and the challenges and the desires
of the dreams of the 836 million Indians
wobble or two dollars a day world vision
works in about 5,300 communities with
our feet on the ground and our hands
dirty so we are very much in touch with
the pulse of the nation and to be able
to connect them to the India's growth
story thank you very much for this
opportunity